hey guys how's it going so this morning
I'm extremely excited because I'm going
to be doing a blindfold taste test of
the new limited edition Star Wars coffee
made coffee creamers now you guys know
me you know pretty much my favorite
thing is is coffee and it is how I
survive and I went out this morning
before Jenna was even awake in search of
all five bottles I had actually got a
two different stores because they were
sold out because people are so freaking
excited about this and I don't even know
about this until you guys tweeted me and
told me this is a thing and I had to
have them all so as soon as I'm done
with a coffee creamer I'm probably just
gonna put these on my shelf is that it
that strangers that I think you put them
in the fridge oh my god I'm gonna be
okay man you're okay we're getting to a
blindfold taste test and clearly I love
my label maker as much as I love coffee
so I decided to make some little labels
for each one of them jenna is going to
pour the creamers into the coffee I'll
be blindfolded and don't tell me if I'm
right and then what I've done here's
what we'll do if you're doing I will
give the camera a thumbs up that were
hands down in that way
I won't tell you start pull pour on the
crimps okay first one I'm gonna grab
these all just get mix them up so I'm
negative up mix it up real nice which
one do we want to do first how much do I
put in I like a lot of cream okay coffee
number one did you mix it up real nice I
did I've got a spoon okay I already know
which one this is which one vanilla
Howard oh my right I can't tell you ah
all right wait that number two was that
right no what really but we were wrong
oh you get the next one's right okay but
some vanilla no how do you think you're
doing so far I don't know I only have
one ago in front in front of your face
mmm what's your guess
this is coffee number two mm-hmm ah I
don't want to smell the creamer oh
that's definitely the spice latte okay
am i right
I can't tell you till the end no this
game is my own game that I made up okay
wait number three so I guessed wait I
don't even know if I'm right or not
so I already guessed vanilla I guess
spice latte how about this you if you
taste something that you think is wrong
you can change your answer okay good
and now can I reek can I reach a sin yes
you can't read tastes I want to check my
phone but I can't know my hats are
closed
number three okay Julian's typical go
good with okay
the force is strong the force is small I
know I should drop this I think this is
vanilla because Vanel is the one that I
drink the most and this tastes like my
mornings so then we need to change one
of your answers if you think that I read
across you did guess vanilla you did
okay wait we can do a retest this is
number one you're gonna another shot
okay
put your little nose here Oh smells like
chocolate okay the chocolate espresso
it's the Darth Vader one okay so that's
your final it definitely is you're not
telling me if I'm right or I can't okay
we're gonna hole up this camera number
four oh it's not labeled you made a mess
don't touch anything okay it's back
hands back okay but where's the drink
Oh supposed to know where the drink is
okay okay we're good oh this is
definitely
mm definitely hazelnut no doubt about it
okay we've got one more left if you
don't get this Oh what what's left I
don't know cuz what if you were wrong
about that
huh I definitely wasn't wrong because
that's one of my favorites also where's
my coffee about here Oh Italian sweet
cream ding ding ding ding ding ding oh
my god I got the one little mix-up when
you corrected yourself so that's pretty
good I want to try oh I can't see so I
have mascara all over my face oh all of
your really you look terrible
do I really have it all over my face
yeah my eyes were closed I was laughing
what should i do should I fix it or
should I just move it roll with um
alright guys well thank you so much for
watching you want to try some of it I am
do I really have it all over my desk oh
yeah wow that's what I have all the time
this one's pretty but this is so easy
hey what a great idea alright guys thank
you so much for watching I want to know
if you guys managed to find any of these
bottles if you did tweet me pictures of
them with you guys use the hashtag epic
bottles hashtag star wars hashtag I am
so excited I could cry
you might ask care all over you really
oh I don't have enough cupholders in my
car for these I'm taking mine I'm taking
this one I don't even down in character
that's mice
I let me see it I do have mascara on my
face
Oh yep all over the face alright bye
guys
love you